dans les vosges une enquête sur
l'assassinât du petit grégory se
poursuit cet après-midi avait lieu la
reconstitution du deuxième acte de la
tragédie
l'assassinât de bernard laroche par jean
marie villemin le père de l'enfant
on avait déployé pour l'occasion de
grands moyenne police eh bien il semble
que cet épisode n'apportera pas
grand-chose à lenquête le reportage de
gérard pinson le juge lambert répondait
aux simples exigences de la procédure
criminelle en organisant cette
reconstitution
cet après midi sur les hauteurs de mons
et s'il n'attendait guère de révélations
le juge en revanche semblé craindre ne
sait quels nouveaux rebondissements
dramatiques dans cette pénible affaire
aux alentours de la maison plus d'une
centaine de gendarmes étaient chargés
d'éloigner journalistes et villageois
quant à jean marie villemin
on l'avait harnaché d'un gilet pare
balles à sa sortie du fourgon
le magistrat instructeur ne voulait
prendre aucun risque
marie-ange laroche ne résistera pas
jusqu'au bout à ses deux heures
d'émotion elle finira par éclater en
sanglots lorsque jean marie villemin
surgissant des boissons fusil à pompe à
la main mimera et remy mort à
l'assassinât de bernard laroche
jean marie villemin qui cet après midi
après trois mois de prison est réapparu
tel que nous le connaissions pâle les
mâchoires serrées
déterminez vous ou même l'impression
qu'il aurait pu refaire feu si
aujourd'hui et dans les mêmes
circonstances que le 29 mars dernier
bernard laroche s'était retrouvé devant
lui le degré de préméditation ce seront
les jurés des vosges peut être en
décembre qui devront l'évaluer mais en
redescendant dans la vallée chacun ce
soir pensait à l'absence de cette
reconstitution
comment en effet oublié christine
villemin le jour des faits elle était
hospitalisée son mari se précipitant
auprès d'elle lui avait dit j'ai fait
cela pour toi aujourd'hui enceinte de
cinq mois
la mère de grégory n'est toujours que
partie civile